[Musique]
l'entretien politique chaque semaine
avec un maire du département des
yvelines échanges autour de l'actualité
et aujourd'hui c'est avec jean roger
davin bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
premier édile de croissy sur seine
depuis 2001 c'est une commune de moins
de 10000 habitants qui appartient
l'agglomération de saint germain boucles
de seine
tout d'abord tout d'abord pardon déjà un
mot sur votre longévité au sein de cette
commune est à la tête de cette commune
19 ans déjà toujours la même
détermination que voue une passion donc
salée la pression ça vous dit pas ça
continue tant que l'équation sont
d'accord avec ce qu'on fait et partage
je pense que nous faisons je pense que
pour qu'il y aura ensemble alors donc
j'évite est effectivement parce que
c'est quand même un atout parce que ça
permet de pouvoir dire que vous partagez
avec les principaux élections est encore
là un certain nombre d'échéances et que
à chaque fois on m'a fait jégo lancer
ses relations avec nos habitants qui
permet d'ailleurs d'avoir cette
longévité il y aurait durant la campagne
forcément vous avez évoqué aussi votre
votre bilan amélioration du cadre de vie
rayonnement de la ville où aussi au
cours de ces vingt dernières années il
ya eu l'euro 2016 le mondial féminin de
football vous aviez accueillir des
équipes on avait eu l'occasion d'en
parler sur cette antenne votre priorité
à présent c'est aussi de renforcer le
pouvoir de décision direct c'est ce que
vous aviez dit à l'époque pendant la
campagne ça se traduit comment et
pourquoi cette volonté aussi vous sentez
une attente de la part des administrés
ont sans rien attendre de la part des
français elle entendait aussi les
administrés oubliez pas qu on est sur le
terrain et que donc comme dirait
certains on est à portée de bafé donc
lasser rapidement on peut rencontrer les
crois sinon pour ma part je suis tous
les dimanches matin sur le marché donc
j'ai l'occasion pour les doigts et puis
le reste du temps en étant vélo est donc
simple au rendez-vous tous les samedis
matin donc j'ai pas de souci pour
rencontrer les gens et je pense que
c'est ça qui fait que on a une bouille
contact et que en même temps ça se passe
à peu près bien un contact malgré le
contexte actuel forcément qui touchent
votre commune comme toutes les autres et
pas seulement à travers la france vous
faites face à cette situation de la co
vide avec des mesures aussi
dans votre ville ça se caractérise comme
ans et puis aujourd'hui dans quel état
d'esprit en tant qu'élus et puis aussi
élu au sein d'une agglomération comme
dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous
aujourd'hui plutôt plutôt inquiet ou
serein sur les semaines à venir
non je peux pas dire que je sois serein
disons que je reste naturel et que je me
dis que la vie doit continuer et qu'on
doit tout faire pour que cette vie
continue donc on effectivement des
mesures à prendre des gestes barrières
pour ce qui concerne la ville de croissy
sur seine et son marché comme on n'a pas
la distanciation physiques suffisantes
donc on est obligé de porter le masque
sur le marché de croatie vendredi et
dimanche pour le reste pour ce qui
concerne l'animation dhabi plus
particulièrement pour homme des
associations de rentrée où la fête de la
vie puisque nous a fait de la carotte
c'est deuxième week-end de septembre
on a décidé en respectant ses gestes
barrières de continuer poursuit cette
fête il n'était pas question pour le
gameplay bien sûr on a été obligé
d'annuler quelques petites choses à
l'intérieur de faire un petit peu
différemment des années précédentes
pas de repas des anciens puisque là on
est au coeur des problématiques peuvent
se passer si on les plus durables
et puis ensuite pour les animations on a
l'habitude d'avoir des stands de
gonflables ou les enfants ou etsaut ce
qui n'était pas possible cette année
donc on a fait un bilan régulier des
viable médiévale on s'est un petit peu
adapté par semaine ce qui est le moins
de contact possible bien sûr port du
masque pour les adultes pas en tant
qu'élu vous vous sentez encadré
aujourd'hui est-ce que les directives
vous semble clair en tout cas je dirais
non pas quand même qu'en simple élu en
tant que citoyen hostie dans les
directives seront pas forcément clair
six ans relativement inutile de se dire
pourquoi d'un côté on aime pourquoi
notre côté on ferme pas donc ce qu'ont
essayé de faire 100 ter dit les mères ou
toujours été tout seul
alors certes aidé mais c'est surtout
qu'ils prennent des décisions et puis ce
qu'on appelle la responsabilité ultime
c'est nous qui la portent la
responsabilité pénale
quand on est quelque chose en place et
qu'on estime qu'on a vraiment tout fait
pour la sécurité puissent se passer
croatie commune d'environ 10000
habitants petite commune au sein d'une
grosse agglomération et on le sait au
delà de la période qu'ovide les la
situation est toujours difficile pour
les communes avec des pertes de revenus
des dotations qui sont parfois en baisse
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui sur
votre commune
bah oui j'ai tendance à dire quand
occupy la dgf puisqu'on avait une date
cela sept ou huit ans en arrière au dg
qui doit nous en restait à peu près cent
cinquante mille euros pour les anciens
baissent donc au moins ça nous évite
d'en parler
par contre ce qui augmente de manière
très forte ça a été les pics donc la
péréquation intercommunale et cette
année on a encore augmenté un peu plus
que ce qu'on a eu la divine surprise en
plein mois de juillet mars de faire
partie des communes i très riches qui
vont subventionner le crif donc je suis
désolé avec des mots comme ça mais là
c'est le fonds régional et donc
forcément le tout ça ça vous regarde la
commune et les finances de la commune
je dois aussi dire que depuis 2001
puisque vous signez dt leur qu'on avait
ténu l'ensemble de nos taux communaux
n'ont pas augmenté non plus ils ont
baissé puisqu'on se retrouve à des taux
communaux de 1997 donc ensuite il faut
jongler avec ce qu'on a dans les
finances pour pouvoir réussir à
continuer la chance que nous avons c'est
quand même dynamique avec un marché
immobilier entraînés dynamique qui nous
permet de récupérer pas mal de droits
sur les transférer et aujourd'hui quelle
est la priorité pour vous sur la commune
dans les prochains mois alors qu vide
à part bien évidemment mais quel est le
gros projet qui devrait vous occuper
pour ce début de mandat
alors on a là aussi l'habitude c'est
être ici pour ça je disais qu'on restait
incertain de temps c'est dans le cadre
de notre programme on bâtit un programme
électoral comme tout et tout le temps
dit da mais en plus on l'à pic derrière
et quand on l'appliqué ont donc donne
des choses et à chaque fois qu'on a mis
des projets sur ce lectorat nous les a
chiffrés et donc on est capable de faire
sur le mandat un chiffrage total et
d'être sûr de pouvoir mettre en place
les projets qu'on a présenté le ton
quand on a fait nos élections on avait
mis huit engagements des projets
importants
ensuite ces projets bien entendu
pourquoi tu fais tout la première année
dans les faits au fur et à mesure alors
avec un peu d'expérience maintenant fait
tout pour passer avant avec un animaux
c'est à dire une personne qui va nous
aider à construire ses projets et une
fois que ces projets sont construits et
qu'on a tous les deux ils sont pas être
déposée on regarde un petit peu et ce
qui se passe d'un point de vue de nos
partenaires j'entends la région le
département
la drac les pins et on regarde quels
sont les taux de subventionnement les
plus intéressants ou ski entre
guillemets à la mode qui nous
permettrait d'avoir le subventionnement
est plus important et en fonction du
projet qu'on a on le met en place de
façon à pouvoir bénéficier d'un
subventionnement important aujourd'hui
puisque vous posez la question on a
décidé de ce qu'on appelle nous de
travailler sur un thème qui est le
culture animation de ville et plus
particulièrement pour ce qui concerne
d'équations s'appelle la maison de la
charité c'est là où vous avez le
regroupement l'ensemble des ateliers
d'art et donc on va faire une
augmentation un agrandissement de ses
locaux à peu près 400 mètres carrés et
qui permettra de regrouper plus
d'ateliers d'art ensemble et surtout
d'avoir une à l'aide un peu plus
importante avec des nouveaux qui
pourraient rentrer merci beaucoup genre
j'ai d'avant maire de croissy sur seine
d'avoir été avec nous et on se retrouve
très vite sur terre et 78 avec un nouvel
élu local du département
[Musique]